un castigo para los responsables y
acciones más amigables con el planeta es
lo que se desprende del decreto que
califica de interés nacional la
emergencia provocada por el cambio
climático esto luego de que unas 21
playas fuesen afectadas por el derrame
de cerca de 6 mil barriles de crudo de
la petrolera repsol estamos de uno de
los lugares más afectados por el derrame
de petróleo ocurrido hace pocos días que
ha significado el desastre ecológico más
preocupante de la costa peruana de los
últimos tiempos esta situación de
acuerdo con la versión de repsol se
produjo luego de que un buque que
abastecía la refinería la pampilla fuese
golpeado por el fuerte oleaje producto
de la erupción volcánica en la isla de
tonga el derrame ha afectado
174 kilómetros cuadrados en el suelo y
118 kilómetros cuadrados en el mar según
el organismo de evaluación y
fiscalización ambiental causando daños
en la flora la fauna y a los cerca de
1.500 pescadores artesanales que
trabajan en la zona pero ahora yo camino
por toda la orilla y los muy estaban
muertos
sacaba mi muy viva mi zona de pesca pero
ahora señor todo tiene olor a muerte el
gobierno peruano ha manifestado que se
han tomado acciones penales civiles y
administrativas por el caso por su parte
la empresa petrolera sostiene que la
situación fue provocada por un fenómeno
marítimo imprevisible
durante todo el tiempo que se prolonguen
la actual situación la compañía contará
con el asesoramiento de expertos
técnicos en la materia y aportará todos
los recursos necesarios la fiscalía
peruana mantiene una investigación por
el presunto delito de contaminación
ambiental contra representantes legales
y funcionarios de la refinería y de
acuerdo con medios peruanos la multa por
este caso podría ascender a 34,5
millones de dólares